I think you know one foot one step at a
time and we'll start of found me
the royal family is expanding very soon
et has learned Megan Marco hit the
six-month mark in her pregnancy and
officially revealed her due date the
Dutchess of Sussex reportedly shared an
update with a woman in the crowd on
Monday during a royal appearance in
Birkenhead England with Prince Harry
while greeting fans Megan was overheard
telling another woman she's expected to
give birth between late April to early
May until now the 37 year old Royals due
date has been unknown since Kensington
Palace announced back in October the
couple was expecting their first child
in the spring still no word on whether
Megan and Harry are having a boy or girl
this pregnancy has probably come as much
of a happy surprise to the couple as it
has to us the rest of the world it's
likely that Megan would have conceived
probably towards the middle or end of
July and that's just two months after
they got married so this is really very
very quick things have happened very
quickly here we're told that the baby is
going to be duped in a spring sources
are telling us that that will most
likely be the beginning to the end of
April could even fall on Prince Louise
first birthday a royal source tells ET
while in Birkenhead today Megan told the
crowds that Megan and Harry are looking
forward to the baby coming she is
feeling really well and Harry will be a
fantastic father I can't wait for the
day
[Music]